we are now joined by congressman Jordan
the first time dealing with all of this
in detail and good evening congressman
yeah you heard that report you've seen
the reports in recent days your reaction
first to all of this it's false I mean I
never saw never heard of never was told
about any type of abuse if I had been I
would have dealt with it our coaching
staff we would have dealt with these
were our student-athletes a good coach
puts it puts the interests of his
student-athletes first we would have
dealt with it if we hadn't known about
anything that happened if in fact there
are victims they deserve justice there's
an investigation going on we're gonna I
think meet with him next week we want
the investigation to to get to the truth
that's what we need here is the truth
all right take a listen to the saboteur
from one of the statements he made
earlier this week I know Jim knew about
the what I call the deviant sexual
atmosphere that we were housed - how do
you we all had conversations jim was
more like a big brother than a coach it
was something that we would discuss on a
regular basis mainly with nervous banter
locker room banter
now there are five at least five one
Politico was saying there's six where
are these guys coming from conversations
in a locker room are a lot different
than allegations of abuse are reported
abuse to us I mean I've been around the
sport of wrestling my entire life
kids wrestling junior high Ross high
school Russell University constant
coached at Ohio State I got two boys who
wrestled for the Badgers I got I got
four nephews who wrestled Ohio State
another nephew who wrestles for Iowa
conversations in a locker room are a lot
of different than people coming up
talking about abuse no one ever reported
any abuse to me if they had I would have
dealt with it and what bothers me the
most is the guys that are saying this
thing I know they know the truth I know
they do done yes yet he wrestled for we
trained with these guys every day
sometimes twice a day and and for I know
what they're saying I know they know
what they're saying is not accurate so
what do you think the motivation is then
you'd have to ask them but I will tell
you with Mike de sabadell
Mike de sabadell has a vendetta against
Ohio State he lost a licensing agreement
with Ohio State he is out to get Ohio
State he has a vendetta against our
family
he was arrested just five months ago
threatening Chris Spielman 'he's lawyer
and Chris fielding he's got all kinds of
lawsuits against him and what bothers me
more than that is the fact that CNN puts
him on TV three times in one day with
with it I mean if if they would have
done they're done their homework instead
of rushing to rushing to put someone on
TV who's who's had a criminal record all
kinds of all kinds of lawsuits again
against him saying these kind of false
things but it and waited for like to get
the real facts about this guy's
background okay well no there are others
you know it's not just him now there are
five
The Wall Street Journal talked to the
former UFC world champion Mark Coleman
who says he has an affinity for you
likes you a lot
but he says quote there's no way unless
he's got dementia or something that he's
got no recollection of what was going on
at Ohio State I have nothing but respect
for this man I love this man but he knew
as far as I'm concerned I feel sorry for
Mark Coleman Mark Coleman was Mark
Coleman Russell Forrest was the national
champ and then was one of our coaches
for several years that it's just not
accurate there is there never was abuse
important to me and if there was we had
to dealt with it Sean Daly former Ohio
State wrestler I participated with
Jimmie and other wrestlers in the locker
room talk about stress we all did is
very common knowledge in the locker room
that if you went to dr. Strauss for
anything you would have to pull down
your pants it goes on to say that you
had said something like if they tried to
do that for a thumb injury I would kill
him
not true did not say it right but let me
ask you congressman you've got these
guys that are now on the record somebody
reading this from outside what do you
say to them what is driving these guys
to say this now yeah you'd have to ask
them I think the timing is a suspect
from when you when you think about how
this whole story came together after the
Rosenstein interview or hearing with
this with this whole talk
about the the speaker's race but it is
just not accurate and as I said before
there's conversations in the locker room
are a lot different than someone coming
up to you and saying there was some kind
of abuse if there had been that we would
have dealt with it coach hellicksen
would have dealt with it our entire
coaching staff we had five code and we'd
have dealt with it these student
athletes so did you hear it in the
locker room no no no no type of abuse we
did not hear that we've had short of
abuse that that that may be considered
abuse now in this current time not did
not and in again the that's the part
that bugs me the most is these guys you
invest so much time with them I remember
done yeah she gets competing and and
just I remember in the Big Ten
semifinals this this guy in a match
where he was he was in a situation where
he was getting hurt and going out on the
mat and helping this guy when when it
happened it's just it is just it's so
frustrating I will say you have a number
of people coming out and you're who
supports you you say they believe you
people who worked there that people a
widow of a fallen marine who had bad
experience ray Mendoza wrestled for us
Mike de sabado setup help set up
establish this fund a memorial fund for
Ray who gave his life for our country as
a marine in Iraq I was at the first
event spoke at that event with coach
hellicksen and coached Russell and Karen
Mendoza Ray's Widow had to shut that
event down had to shut that that fund
down because of my couldn't account
where for where the money was going had
to go to the Attorney General to shut
that down to use a veteran who a Marine
who gave his life for our country to use
that as a way for personal gain is is is
is as wrong as it gets and this is the
guy that the media puts on TV three
times in one day to make all these false
statements without going back and check
in his the the fact that he's in
financial distress and as a criminal
record it is just we're gonna try to
follow up and have tried to reach out to
him as well
I heard you yesterday I think talk about
the law firm that's involved in this
investigation it is the same law firm
you mentioned that dealt with the
dossier that you are obviously dealing
yes and you are you suggesting that this
is some sort of conspiracy I'm not
saying that all I'm saying is they said
they reached out to us they sent it to a
non-existent email address so think it
was perkins in court that perkins cuy
that hillary clinton's law firm so the
same law firm that can that can find an
expert or spy to put together a dossier
to go after president Trump can't find
the congressman's email address can't
get a hold of me and then they tell the
press we reached out to me didn't
respond that is just complete bogus and
I mean Brett when I go when I'm we have
one of these hearings in Congress I tell
you one thing every liberal in the
country seems to be able to find our
phone number and find our address and
call us up but this law firm who's
supposedly doing this investigation
couldn't couldn't find that you didn't
receive an email from them we did not
you didn't receive any contact from them
they had not contact now they've been in
contest in contact with us since that
since that said they said that and we're
gonna sit down with them we want we want
to get to the truth if there were people
who were abused they deserve justice but
what has been said about me is is
completely false and it's been said by
one individual who spent 18 months in
prison for fraud another individual who
has this vendetta against Ohio State who
was bilking a fallen marines fund who
who has numerous lawsuits and and was
arrested yeah the kind of guy that press
just to be clear you before the guys who
have also come out mark Coleman Sean
Daly who said he was groped a half dozen
times by dr. Richard Strauss you don't
know their motivation I don't I don't
but what I'm telling you is it's not
true well I said as you know in these
stories what happens is a lot of things
start coming out Politico has just moved
to stories saying that there were four
years lawyers in a hall a building that
housed the athletic teams and that the
head coach was hellicksen what at times
have to physically draw drag these
Gawker's out because they were looking
at
your wrestlers showering and and doing
various things and that you as the
number two would do that as well I never
drug anyone out I would say that our
Larkins Hall was one of the largest
intramural facilities in the country on
one of the largest campuses on the
country our wrestling locker room was
separate but the but the shower facility
was part of the general population for
the students the faculty professors and
staff and everyone could could shower
there so but again never sell any type
of abuse there and never drugged anyone
out but it was in a large intramural
typhus a lot of people will say why did
you spend so much time on this in the
show and we wanted you to address these
allegations head-on you are going to
continue to address them but what do you
think the next step is here we're gonna
get the truth out the thing that I've
been most encouraged by is the number of
wrestlers and coaches who have contacted
us and said Jim this is bogus we got a
whole list of folks who Synanon
statement saying this is ridiculous we
were there we know you that's been
encouraging and the thing that's been
most disappointing is these athletes who
you spent most so much time with working
out with and training with saying things
that just just are not true because
you're the most high profile currently
Mike de sabadell
his whole pattern is to latch on to high
profile people for personal gain Chris
Spielman and then he asked he gets
harasses Pillman's a lawyer and is
arrested for it Karen Mendoza who sets
up a fund for ray Mendoza who was a big
tin runner up for us was a great kid I
recruited that kid for out of New Jersey
gate gave everything he had for us and
then gave everything he had for our
country and and he's taken money from
that fund and and CNN puts him on three
times to say things that are not true
that that's a part and I worked with
Mike I worked with dunyasha
when dunyasha gets was wrestling in the
Big Ten semifinals in a in a huge match
he's in this scramble position and he
gets choked out and I see it coming I
see what's getting ready to happen and
coach HELOCs and I are starting to run
on the net because the ref doesn't see
it
is out we're there I mean that's what
coaches do they look out for their kids
they look out for their student-athletes
I had a great coach in high school coach
makan was the the best teacher in our
school the toughest teacher in our
school and that and the best best
wrestling coach in the state he talked
about discipline coach hellicksen did so
much for me when he was my coach and for
guys that that I know they know I know
they know what they're saying is not
true I know they know that and there's
and they're saying anyway and and what
they did to Ray Mendoza is fun is is
congressman you've been in politics a
long time last thing is this the
toughest thing you've had to do it's
been the toughest week I mean it just
been tough for a fan it's been them I
mean I look I don't want to it just been
but but there's lots of things that
people have to go through tough things
what had just been an emotional week I
should say because our son got married
last Saturday this all happened last
night we lost we lost a nephew he was
killing Russell's for the University
Wisconsin he's a junior national
qualifier wonderful kid and was was
killed in a car wreck last night
traveling out to Iowa to see his sister
who's the statistician for the Iowa
wrestling team and but look I mean all
kinds of Americans have to deal with
tough things but but this is wrong I is
just wrong congressman sorry for your
loss your family's lost we appreciate
you dealing with these allegations on
the show and we'll continue to follow it
thanks Brett